i think you might have saved the biggest
one for last well danny that's right
believe it or not i've got more things
to show to you so how about we take a
leap of faith into the future together
let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
well i think that's what you call big
news isn't it i mean there's a lot of
stuff in there that i think from your
point of view certainly the community
the fans have been asking for for a long
time so mac tell us more well this is
code name red our next premium flagship
title and the future of our open world
rpg games on assassin's creed
it is being developed by ubisoft quebec
the studio behind assassin's creed
odyssey under the creative direction of
jonathan zuma
it will let players explore one of their
most awaited settings ever on the
franchise feudal japan and they'll live
a very powerful shinobi fantasy i mean
people have been waiting for this for a
long time haven't they yes they have
they certainly haven't now you brought
it to them it's amazing which is good
and you're slightly cruel in that you're
teasing me with it i very much want that
you mentioned um some of the other
studios uh what's montreal up to right
now well we have our veteran team behind
assassin's creed valhalla in montreal
the birthplace of assassins creed who's
been hard at work on a new flagship
title as well it is being led by
creative director clint hawking it is a
very different type of assassin's creed
game
and i believe you may have brought us
something that we can watch now yes here
it is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well the surprises just keep on coming
what can you tell us about this project
well this is code name hexay and i can't
wait for our fans to tear apart that
trailer and find out all its secrets
yeah absolutely and work out the code
now you guys have always got code names
for stuff there was um was it a year ago
there was
code name infinity
wary with that well that's a great
question danny and i'm happy to give you
a little bit more about project infinity
uh today
infinity is not a game per se it's going
to be the single entry point for our
fans into the assassin's creed franchise
into the future so are you saying that
players will be able to explore their
very own animus kind of like a time
machine exactly alice infinity is going
to be a hub that will unite all our
different experiences and our players
together in meaningful ways so
obviously that begs the question if
you're connecting players and there's
more than one player a lot of people
will be thinking are we talking
multiplayer
well danny it seems we can't hide
anything from you so we're actually
investigating how uh we will bring back
stand-alone multiplayer experiences into
the assassin's creed universe
all connected to the infinity hub
well it sounds extraordinary you must
have a nap at some point because you've
all been very very busy so our thanks
mack
some major new developments there and
i'm sure everyone at home can't wait to
get involved and thank you for joining
us today and sharing all this incredibly
exciting news well thank you danny thank
you alice it's been a pleasure to be
here and to be finally able to share all
these great things that we have coming
for our fans